[Music]
at the beginning of fourth grade I
joined peer offers peer helpers is an
inclusion program for students like
myself can interact with students in
special education when I joined I was
looking to try something new because you
see at my elementary school there is
only the Chess Club and peer helpers so
my options are pretty limited but the
kids that I did see pure helping looked
like they were having tons of fun I mean
they were missing class sitting together
at lunch and taking trips I wanted in on
that so I joined at the time I had no
idea I would eventually be meeting
someone who would become one of my
closest friends today Henley Hager
when I first met him Lee and his family
it was a disaster I vividly remember
talking to Mateo for the first time and
I had no idea what to say it was
probably something like hey miss Hagar
and was here to work with him Lee so
after I introduced myself to her I
finally met Henley the boy I was going
to be working with at first I didn't
know what to do or say around Henley you
see him Lee has severe autism and I had
no experience working with anyone like
that before I'm going to be honest it's
not like I just strolled in there and
was already best buddies with him I was
nervous nervous that I might set him off
or nervous that I might do something to
upset him and since we're being honest I
was nervous because we as humans have a
tendency to feel uncomfortable around
people who are different than us
regardless over the next three years
every Wednesday I went with somebody to
an after-school program where we'd work
on social and academic skills such as
organization doing homework physical
exercise calming down helping him - and
days plan not complainingly it doesn't
get his way engaging in small talk but
as long as I've known him Lee I know
what he wants to do play on the computer
but we can't always do that
so I'll provide other examples of what
we can do like walk around the track
he's the stationary bike or play
basketball
Oh answer with yes or no or he's gotten
to the point where he will politely ask
if we can do this activity and said over
the years
Henley's Smalltalk has greatly improved
and it's not just with me it's with
every person he interacts with that's
one of the goals of inclusion programs
inclusion programs benefit people
because they develop friendships
increase achievement of IEP goals and
greater opportunities for enhance
learning or formed but apart from all
that we would go from places I remember
one time Henley and I went to McWane
Science Center in downtown Birmingham we
had fun watching the fish and stingrays
and sharks but imagine being at the
Science Center and hearing two teenage
boys cracking up and giggling over
nothing
Henley and I can just set out a quick
giggle and the lab techs begin but the
best time ever when I'm with him and I
always look forward to spending time
with him but the trip wasn't me being
his peer helper these were just two best
friends hanging out and watching sharks
now I can talk about how much I've done
with or for Henley but what I really
want you to hear and what rarely gets
mentioned is the fact that Henley has
also helped me he saw me become more
patient I am better at working with kids
with disabilities and I believe I become
more compassionate toward those
different than me
so through minor actions with Henley I
mentioned becoming more patient for
example Henley takes longer to learn
certain concepts to do schoolwork and
respond to certain questions and because
of this I've wanted to repeat myself
without getting frustrated or at least
making that frustration visible somebody
should teach my mom back but let me be
clear many times it was frustrating but
you can't get mad at him because he's
not intentionally trying to be difficult
he's just taking his time and adjusting
to the task at hand the best way he
knows how understanding this made me a
more patient person in all aspects of
life and apart from patience I become
better at working with kids with special
needs in your everyday school a majority
of students pretend like students and
the special Department don't even exist
they walk through the halls talk to
their friends and ignore those with
special needs rarely do people interact
with these students in a positive and
helpful way but I've learned that
through interacting with students like
Henley when you ignore those with
special needs you're missing out on a
gift
so from fourth to seventh grade I work
exclusively with Henley and that
partnership that friendship is one of
the best things that has ever happened
to me I have loved working with Henley
and becoming up your hoper one of the
best decisions of my life but sadly not
all students have this opportunity after
researching I was shocked to find that
people with special needs do not have
enough if any peer helpers in their
school and what's worse not all schools
provide enough teachers or teachers
aides to students in the special ed
Department so you're ready for this part
many students in the special ed
department don't receive the adequate
services they deserve and other schools
who don't provide the adequate services
to these students I believe the most
common reason is because they don't have
enough funding or staff but if they're
not up to standard it's the students who
suffer think of all the kids with
learning disabilities and how they need
help to survive in their learning
without it jobs may not be available to
them or they may not learn social skills
needed to live in the environment we
live in today their autonomy won't
develop and these richer relationships
will not be formed all of these concepts
rotate around each other and the things
that I work with something to improve on
I can tell that Henley has greatly
improved with communicating with people
throughout the years and this is because
he's fortunate enough to live in a
community that has a very respectable
special education program with many
staff members in a thriving proper
program but like I said before not all
schools a majority in fact adequately
support the special education department
which is making it harder for these kids
to become the most successful version of
themselves but now let's say schools do
start providing the help they should be
giving to these kids let's say that
these students thrive
I mean think of the possibilities they'd
be prepared to the workforce and they
learn stronger social skills if the
schools are not providing enough
teachers or teacher dates to students in
the special department I say that job is
tough to us the students I see the
students should step up and support
their fellow classmates every student in
here has the ability to help the hardest
part is acting on the problem but I know
everyone can do it
one of the best and most effective ways
you can help special education
departments is by creating or joining a
peer upper program once you join one of
these programs you'll feel like a
different person because you realize how
much of an impact you have on other
individuals because helping others
impacts you it turns you into a glass
half-full person and essentially those
stronger friendships with those who need
it so aside from lunch being a peer
offer is the best part of school by a
landslide so those of you who enjoy
learning just wait until you become a
peer helper every Tuesday in some
Thursdays I help and when I get to
school I'm so excited I'm excited for
the time of day I can walk into that
room and say hello to all my friends who
I enjoy helping be coming up you're over
should be considered a privilege because
not only are you positively impacting
your fellow peers they also help you and
you'll build long-standing relationships
from this as well it is hard work
sometimes and you're definitely not
going to get a trophy saying you're good
for your hoper but really who needs a
trophy when you're gaining a friend
that's the best reward being a peer
offer helped me realize Who I am as a
person and my purpose and not just my
life but others lives too so I challenge
my fellow students in the audience to
strongly consider becoming a peer helper
you will love it and if you don't have
one talk with your principal or Board of
Education and make one because these
students really needed and you parents
listening out there encourage your son
or daughter to participate in peer
helper programs because all it takes is
eight words to change your life and the
lives of others I would like to become a
peer helper thank you
[Applause]